Hi, my name is Donna and my name is Austin,
and we'd love to share with you
how God has written our family story through adoption.
Austin and I were married in 2003 and soon
after we became pregnant,
but at four months, our son's heart stopped beating
without ever holding him.
We had to say goodbye.
That loss was devastating,
but even then, we clung to the truth that God had a plan.
In 2007, Austin joined the army
and just a couple years later,
he was deployed to Afghanistan.
While on guard duty, he was shot by a fellow soldier.
He spent 21 months in the hospital
and our life was forever changed,
but again, we knew God still had a plan.
Years later, when we tried to start a family, we found out
because of Austin's injury, we wouldn't be able
to have children together.
Biologically, God began stirring adoption in our hearts
and we knew that was the path he had for us.
The process was anything but simple.
We experienced false starts and disappointments.
A baby girl we prayed for but didn't bring home,
and a baby boy we were told would be ours only to have
that fall through overnight.
We were heartbroken. Yet God kept whispering,
don't give up, trust me.
And sure enough, that same little boy came back into our
lives at just four days old, Gabriel was in the nicu,
and even though we left him de handed at first,
God made a way through prayer court hearings
and a law that allowed us to intervene.
Gabriel came home to us
and three months later we finalized his adoption.
Gabriel is funny, smart, and full of faith.
He keeps us on our toes with his questions about God
and his boldness to stand up for his friends.
We thought our family was complete,
but God had another plan.
And in 2018,
a distant relative brought us a baby girl who needed a home.
We prayed and prayed,
and soon in Berlin came to live with us.
Her journey was long with years of paperwork
and delays, especially through C,
but in December of 2021, she officially became our daughter.
Linn is our princess with a little bit of spice.
She is kind, loves Jesus,
and has a fierce determination in everything she does
Through loss, injury, waiting
and heartbreak, we've learned that adoption is not easy,
but it is beautiful.
There's no DNA shared yet.
We look at our kids and see so many ways.
God has knit us together as a family. Too often we hear you.
Your kids are so lucky to have you,
but the truth is, we are the lucky ones, Gabriel,
and are the greatest gifts God could have given us.
If you ever feel the smallest tug towards adoption, I want
to encourage you, don't ignore it.
There are so many children who long for a home, a family,
and the safety of being loved.
None of them chose their beginning story,
but you can choose to show them God's love.
We never imagined this would be our journey,
but we wouldn't change a thing
because through it all, God has shown us
that he truly had a plan.